je voudrais avoir Raymon là-dessus parce
que je pense que là c'est être le plus
virulent non pas virulent c'est juste
que moi je quand quand vous dites ais
parce que non parce que ça fait mal de
voir ça en fait en fait ça fait très mal
de voir ça parce que quand vous dites il
y a pas longtemps vous m'avez expliqué
que le premier ministre il touchait
15000 € c'était mérité parce que le
matin il se lèv et le soir il se couche
là c'est la même chose ils toucheent
7000 € ils ont combien de frais avant
l'augmentation
550 plus 11000 pour les cur plus 11000
mais compr attendez attendez les gars
les gars les gars vous m'expliquez là je
vous je vous dis ce que je pense moi VO
vous me dites encore mais les députés
ils travaillent beaucoup ils se lèvent
le matin ils se couchent le soir il y a
beaucoup de Français qui se lèvent le
matin et qui se couchent le soir vous me
dites que c'est vous me dites que
attends vous me dites que c'est les
frais de déplacement mais les Français
ils vont au boulot comment en
hélicoptère en yaach en bateau ils se
déplacent aussi les Français on leur
donne pas 300 €. et oui mon pote et la
plus grosse erreur c'est ce que tu as
fait toi Guillaume et c'est ce que tu as
fait toi jeanm et c'est ce que font les
gens sur les réseaux sociaux oui mais
vous vous êtes payé pour rester cul ass
sur une chaise alors c'est vrai ils ont
raison les gens on est payé pour rester
le cul ass sur une chaise mais c'est pas
l'argent des Français c'est pas les
impôts on pas député nous on paslu de la
son argent à lui c'est l'argent c'est un
groupe privé alors quand tu dis à
Valérie oui mais toi tu vas être
augmenté Valérie va être augmenté et
elle va payer des impôts pour payer les
députés tu vois c'est ça le problème
c'est ça problème il pay des impôts AEL
argent avec quel argent
avec que 15000 € par mois il faut encore
leur donner 300 € pendant que les gens
il payent l'électricité plus cher et là
on va aller dans la démagogie pendant
que les gens il payent la bouffe pendant
que les gens il crève pendant que les
mecs il vont dormir avec des sans abris
si vous pensez qu' faut le donner 300
balles à ce momentl là au mois de
janvier le 25 janvier s'il fallait
donner 300 balles et ben allez-y donnez
300 balles mais moi je vous disrê de
dire
[__] ça parce que s étai pay moins il y
aurait des
PR s travaill dans le privé il gagner
plusors pourquoi ils y vont pas et ben
parce qu'ils ont le sens de dis parce
que la gamelle elle est bonne il y a pas
de sens de l'État la gamelle elle est
bonne Guillaume et Radouan vous parlez
trop dire
comp on les entend parler
là non mais les noms c'est incroyable
vous savez ce qu'il y a dans les vous
savez ce qu'il y a dans les 5950 € vous
savez ce qu'il y a il y a la
documentationous mon il y a les gardes
d'enfants quand on bosse la [__] c'est
normal arrêtez il y a les fris de
déplacement il y a l'ébergement il y a
les réceptions il y a la représentation
mais c'est totalement délirant à tel
point que à tel point que c'est
tellement fort 5900 € qu'il y a que 10 %
des députés qui dépensent ça tellement
c'est délirant les autres ils disent on
sait pas quoi en faire on leur redonne
300 non mais vous êtes malad 6000 balles
pour garder les enfants et de la
documentation vous êtes dans quel monde
vous êtes délirant les agriculteurs
crèvent de faim il se donnent 300 € de
plus
jeich
même c'est honte ce que dites
maisz pour une
fois je trouve
queich amis on
pour pas amis
sontstenis cont
amisé
alors question non moi moi je suis
totalement Daniel g rmon effectivement
je trouve que et toiid mais toi Ctait
parfait non non effectivement le timing
est catastrophque je trouve que c'est
indécent c'est provocquant c'est
dégueulasse pardon il y a pas de bon
timing dans ce genre de
chose le pays est fracturé et déchiré
Paris va être bloqué la France est
bloquée les gens crèvent de faim je on
le ajoute 300 balles c'est pas possible
en fait c'est inaudible et effectivement
on se demande comment ça leur vient
l'idée les politiques ENF les députés de
faire cette mesure là à ce momentl Rapp
on va rappeler les avantages aussi des
députés en plus de accès illimité au
service de la RTP et SNCF merci 80 vols
entre Paris et la circonscription merci
12 vols pour toute destination en
métropole pour l'élu et son conjoint
merci repas au restaurant de l'Assemblée
allocation de garde d'enfants de moins
de 3 ans de
323,76 pay arrête
arrêteour loyer parisien à hauteur de
1200 € par mois merci voilà ça c'est des
voilà il y a rien qui vous choque t ceux
qui t ceux qu'on dit c'est normal quand
vous entendez ça je ne veux pas faire
politique moi je suis très bien dans le
privé moi je suis très bien ici je suis
très bien dans mon camion je suis bien
dans le privé je ne veux pas faire de
politique moi m toi non toi si tu
commences à dire 300 € c'est rien on
leur donne ils ont raison ils ont raison
allez-y je te dis tu connais pas la
c'est facile rés
viich qui gagnerit plus dans le privé je
c'est les mecs qui bossent la journée la
nuit tous les weekends il a pas un jour
de vacances pour t députés il a ce que
oui ils sont leend la semaine à Paris
pour voter les lois pour des rendez-vous
le weekend ils ont des rendez-vous toute
la journée avec le c'est
normal boulot de malade jour c'est
facile de résumer salais qu'on
écouteon écoute
pa je suis choqué choc ah oui je suis
très très choqué depu à l'heure je lui
dis il cro pas je très
pouro tu rigol c'est vrai je suis choqué
parce que avec tout ce qui se passe à
quelle heure ça c'est la priorité et en
plus 300 30000 ça fait un grand chif au
final moi je trou ça indécent voilà donc
toi tu es vénère oui et lui il dit tout
ça juste parce qu'il veut être député
c'est c'est vrai il dit tout ça parce
qu'il va re disputé oui comment tu sais
il me l'a dit quand en off non quand
c'est fou c'est
vrai je rigole c'est même chose non mais
c'est n'importe quoi on a des infos il y
a jamais autant d'agression sur les
députés sur les maires plus personne
dans le métro le matin Raymon a dit une
énorme connerie il a dit c'est non mais
tu as dit tu as dit comment ils payent
leurs impôts tout à l'heure tu parlais
de leur impôt on disait que c'était une
somme brute et après impôt il le reste
que 4500 €. c'est la même chose qui
s'applique au haut fonctionnaires à ce
compel il y a plus de fonctionnaire qui
t'a dit que j'ai dit qu'il payit pas
d'IMP non tu as dit c'est l'argent
appartient à qui ouais tu nous demandé
app l'argent et les fonctionnaires
répond à ma question qui leur donne les
sous qui touchent les députés qui le
donne
l'état il est
fonctionna o Conner quand je te dis que
c'est les Français qui les payent o j'ai
connerie mais les impôts c'est pas les
Français qui les pay
toalune
connaisscom
de alors l'argent du privé
c'est
l'argent du privé c'est qui mais il y a
des agrconomi mais l'argent deé r à ma
question
est il m'a répondu l'argent de l'État
c'est quoi l'État mais c'est totalement
et qui paye les prof c'est l'état et
c'est qui qui P l'é ça
cheveux as trop jou a
ton
calme-toi un peu s'il te plaît
toi il commence à me dire non oublie la
dé ou la démagogie tu dis connerie c'est
l'argent de l'État je te pose une
question qui donne de l'argent à l'état
d'accord
cont par toi tu veux augmenter les
députés à 14000 c'est ça non moi je pour
qu'on baisse le nombre de députés et
qu'on les paye bien les députés aux
États-Unis membr du Cong il en a 100 ils
ont du pouvoir mec ils sont incorruptibl
arrêtez avec l'Angleterre les États-Unis
l'Italie l'Espagne moi je regarde ce qui
se passe ici moi je m'en fous de ce qui
se passe aux États-Unis arrêtez tous les
soirs et les États-Unis allez vivre aux
États-Unis qu'est-ce que j'en ai à fout
des États-Unis honnêtement les
mecsatis pour
parleratsis
je vais me faire engueuler je look
américain c'est pas Patriot franchement
oui 44 onait pas rien si tu veux
[Applaudissements]
44 très mauvaise
émission très mauvaise émission
franchement g au MO quelquun
d'intéressant l'enveloppe globale des
députés si on prend tout c'est 25000 €
par mois vous vous rendez compte
collaborateurs les mais laisse-m tu es
chiant au bout d'un momentarrêes pas de
parler tu répètes tes trois fiches que
tu as
lu'il PL ouais mais c'est bon là le
playboy de bfor ferme ta
[Applaudissements]
gueule je je mon frère oh je
[Rires]
meursère je mon
frère
[Rires]
j'aifou AR arr le playboy
de alors ouis qu'est-ce qu' non
mais je meurs mon frère comment vous
pouvez expliquer au français 10 % de ha
de l'électricité la franchise sur les
médicaments doublés et et les
privilégiés qui s'augmentent mais c'est
inaudible vous êtes fous vous êtes dans
un monde parallèle on dirait les B les
privil mais toi
aussi êes que les gens ne connaissent
pas arrêtez un peu reprenez-vous
Jean-Michel reprends-toi tu as les yeux
dans le
[Applaudissements]
vagueend mais des rageux doublés
d'hypocrite rageux parce que quand on
vous écoute ça ve dire que n'importe
quelle personne pay par l'État devrait
gagner le SMIC voir rien du tout
c'est ce n'est pas parce qu'on travaille
pour l'État qu'on ne vaut rien on a le
droit d'avoir des salaires différents
déjà première chose et deuxièmement
hypocrite l'argent c'est toujours un
problème quand c'est les autres qui en
gagnent quand c'est vous c'est pas un
problème sil faut donner de l'argent
pour les agriculteurs pour les Français
qui en ont besoin donne ton argent vot
arentorsi
imp ser à quoi l'argent que tu dones me
dans
al je vis dire à Jean-Michel mer tout le
monde le dit que les députés prennent
des vacances bien sûr
ilch je déf je sais vous travaillez
énormément c'est pas le débat mais je
met de suivre un député par toute une
semaine il bosse comme
jamais les agriculteurs qui sont en ce
moment dans les
ragin je vous dis maintenant celui qui
lève pas la main pour parler je sors
directement c'est clair c'est clair ce
que je te dis ok donc tu remets ton son
ce je dis merci g qu'est-ce que tu
voulais mon chéri non mais c'est
complètement Jean-Michel vous êtes
totalement horors sol vous vous rendez
compte il y a des agriculteurs là qui
luttent pour leur survie il y a des
commerçants qui se ferment on vient d'en
entendre une une dame une jeune fille
qui ferme son commerce englué sous les
charges d'électricité et ces gens-là
s'augmentent ils ont déjà 25000 ce sera
25300 mais comment vous pouvez
humainement justifier ça je ne comprends
même pas que vous répondiez non je
comprends même pas quelqu'un qui gagne
deux fois plus qu'un député critique
des je voulais dire ça va sortir ça va ê
aussi simple que ça non on paye des
impôts Jean-Michel a aussi ah mais avec
l'argent de qui- que tu veux mais je dis
le problème c'est que tu crois qu'on
critique les députés ce n'est pas ce
qu'on dit on ne dit pas qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont tir au flanc on dit pas tous
pourr c'est pas ce qu'on dit on dit
qu'ils gagnent déjà très bien peut-être
effectivement pas assez c'est pas le
problème là la question est
est
mais
dis mais onand je on te dit que
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle le
symbole est désastreux et inaudible
c'est tout ce qu'on dit parce que c'est
visible nous command dansation personne
ne sait il pas de B minutes minutes j'ai
une nouvelle boisson
elle est incroyable pê hibiscus oh ouais
ça va direct dans
l'anus oui gadine non et puis je pardon
tu crois que c'est vraiment ça
l'augmentation prioritaire quand tu vois
comment les les profs il galèent pour
faire augmenter les infirmiers les aides
soignantes c'est eux la priorité mais si
c'est ça le problème en fait le signal
que tu dois donner
évidment vous êtes témoins une
menace tu peux fermer ta gueule merci
c'est ces gensl que tu dois augmenter
c'est pas eux que tu dois augmenter
est-ce que j'ai dit que j'étais contre
l'augmentation des infirmiers en fait en
PR non mais le problème c'est qu'on a
une enveloppe l'enveloppe elle est pas
extensible donc déjà qu'on est archi
archi archi endetté qu'on n peut plus en
priorité c'est 300 € symboliquement et
donne les moyens aux députés de défendre
le leurs infirmiers dans leur région et
cetera de défendre leurs administrés les
frais de représentation ça fait partie
d'enveloppe tu crois que vraiment
aujourd'hui le problème c'est de faire
des brochings et de bien s'habiller
alors les chér il y a quelquun qui dit
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
Patrick Patrick coltier euh Cyril
Hanouna TPMP avant de récupérer 300 €
les députés auraient pu réformer leur
régime de retraite qu'ils ont conservé
intact un mandat 4 ans de taf 1000 € de
retraite automatique baisser leur
régime c'est pas mal ça bravo patri
il y a un autre scandale je vais vous
dire cette enveloppe de frais elle est
versée au députés au début de chaque
mois d'accord c'està-dire que c'est même
pas après sur facture on leur verse
avant détail ça un détail et ben je vais
vous et ben regardez ce qui est pas un
détail les agriculteurs en ce moment qui
galèrent pour leur Gasol pour leur
tracteur ok ils payent ils remplissent
25000 papiers administratifs et 1 an
après on leur rembourse leur c'est pas
un
juste
agriculteurculisc ça va direct dans
l'anus ça faire du bien
merci oui alors qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'
veut
parlercellent
beauoup j'adore je commence même à tes
amis pas V contre c'est pas possible
d'entendre les députés ils travaillent
toute la journée du matin jusqu'au soir
ils ont jamais de vacances ils vont
jamais au restaurant 2h le midi ils font
jamais rien
un le maçon le
boulanger dis
[Rires]
distis
c'est
bon qui-ce qui a racheté une Porche
àenton
hier fais parce que quand ça descend ça
c'estc c'estbiscus ça va direct dans la
je sais ça co déjà ça va dans le
directement je l'ai racheté avec avec un
crédit des intérêts de la TV pour
pouvoir payer tes députés à moitié prix
je te raconte moi je te raconte fais pas
cher je te raconte
raconte qui P la TVA et dép qui achète
des porchour c'est pas une question de
voiture excuse-moi JeanMichel tu en a
pas une Porche toi elle est
[Applaudissements]
VI alors pour la peine je te laisse 2
minutes tu sais quoi tu as 2 minutes tu
es tout seul à parler tu défonces tous
ceux qui t'ont emmerd ah bah ça de
gauche à droite alors vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y tu peux tu peux démarrer par
j'entour avec toi donc voilà alors après
tu démarres galdine je je vais
m'attaquer au aux deux qui méritent le
plus de les deux bouffons quoi tu peux y
aller vasy tu peux y aller quand tu dis
qu'ils sont pays c'est nos impôts c'est
taxé à la bouche nos impôs qui
imp il y a combien de fonctionnaires en
France toi tu boses pas tes dossiers moi
non plus je le sais pas
d'accord et tout le monde est payé par
les imp voilà c'est c'est le principe
voilà c'est c'est c'est le principe
c'est la France dans tous les pays comme
ça les fonctionnaires sont payés par
l'État les députés sont payés tu vouz
les faire payer par qui par nestley par
Orangina non il sont pay
c'est pas problème qu qu tu soutiens t
amis à longueur de
tempses amis est-ce qu'ils sont élevés
est-ce qu'il sont mis deboutils ont
quitté l'Assemblée pour refuser les 300
non s dans les fouilles comme toi tu
t'es mis dans les fouilles tout l'argent
que donne de façon indu Cyr année aprs
année pour raconter des sornettes et des
conneries de
[Applaudissements]
journé